مخيم جباليا شمال قطاع غزه عاش لساعات
لحظات كانت مفجعه ومؤلمه لجميع شهود
العيال
والجيران الذين كانوا يقتنون بجوار هذا
المبنى السكني والذي يتبع لعائله ابو ريه
هذه العائله التي كانت تحتفل بوصول احد
ابنائها من مصر بعد ان نال شهاده
الدكتوراه وكان تجمع عائلي
بامتياز وصل اليوم وكان الاجتماع العائلي
كما ذكرتوا من تم اندلعت النيران في هذا
الطابق بشكل سريع همم الجيران قاموا ب همم
الدفاع المدني الذي وصل والشرطه والدفاع
المدني ايضا بالاضافه لسيارات الاسعاف
والمطافي ولكن طبيعه المخيمات في قطاع غزه
مرتضى مباني متلاصقه الوصول اليها بشكل
سريع جدا هو امر صعب ايضا عن ماليه
الاطفاء استغ اكثر من 20 دقيقه او اكثر من
نصف ساعه امتد هذا الامر لم يتمكن الدفاع
المدني من الدخول الى المبنى السكني بسرعه
لانتشال اذا كان هناك مصابين لانه للاسف
وزاره الداخليه وزاره الصحه اعلنت وفاه
جميع من كانوا في المبنى ولا يوجد اصابات
21 شخصا من بينهم اكثر من 15 طفلا من
عائله واحده همم تم وفاتهم خلال هذا
الحريق الكبير الذي كان من احد اسباب سرعه
انتشاره الهائل بهذا الشكل هو تخزين
العائله للوقود وهذا يعني امر متداول في
اغلب المنازل في قطاع غزه ولكن السبب
للشراره لهذه
الاشتعال غير معروف غير محدد